ten
pbr
puf キュッ
こんにちははじめ社長ですお前等最近笑ったことあるか
俺はないここ1か月おりゃ心がながらってことがないんだ
やたらそんなことはないと思うねえなこれやねちょっとでとってはないもの3月だった
よ
はいこちらです第1章っっ
第楽章ということでずいっつも入れると30秒文はライド戦慄すられて笑いが止まら
ない
っていうそういうので最初に買ってきました場所は何がちょっとアレだよ
いわゆるアレであっ
ええええええ
いわゆるあれですよこういう米ぐるみで電池を入れてこのわかること等エミーに働いて
いる
このボタンを押すとこいつらでは買いだそうですよ
多分でこうて劇って小腹んですけどそのはらにつられてね
こうだけどねみたいにね子供もつられて笑っつって言うけど僕はもう大人なんでこんな
言葉ダーツ残って僕は引っかからないこいつの仲間こいつはその3体あるって全部出し
ます
こういう感じでも3体だしましたこんにちはあはーい今日は後いうわけでねこれ子供用
なんでた動くみたいなちょっと笑いのツボが深い人には聞けないと思うんですよ
53台全4一間にその発動させて笑いの戦列を起こしてねまあこいつ反対もいれば凄い
んじゃダム
おっ
もうなんか問われた嘘の中で僕が答えるっていうね電池何ホットの3本大学で六法地区
のでぱっぺちされなくに別足りない
イダーほどれたほどれた風を撮る w 全治が12個あるんで
電池を入れて電池入れますはいという準備ができたので早速
一気に鳴らしてみようと思います
マジではまた1回のだらしないからすぐに笑わないと思いますよ僕
みんなもやってみてくださいちょっと本当に
笑っちゃダメです今からじゃあ行きます
はっはっは
ああああああ
はぁ
ああああああああ
be sure